hi I'm escrow Lawrence I'm a model and
I'm here with glamour UK to share the 10
things that make me feel empowered my
squad
they are my cheerleaders they are my
support system they always hyped me up
[Music]
I have this whole community online I may
empower me to be the best person I can
possibly be being in my bikini or even
in my undies and feeling confident in my
body this is the home I'm in this is my
vessel for being appreciating that it
isn't perfect and loving it regardless
[Music]
being able to wear no makeup but also
loving playing with makeup you have to
freedom to be who you want day to day
and kind of like glam up or be super
chill and just keep it fresh
[Music]
I did my TED talk last year and it was
the most nerve-wracking thing I've ever
done in my life but at the same time I
felt so empowered because I was sharing
something that I was passionate about
that I'd written myself and that I was
sharing and gifting to the world I love
music and music makes me feel different
things it cannot lift me and so I think
it's a really powerful tool to be fierce
to be sassy all those good things
[Music]
working with brands and working with
associations and charities that are
doing something to empower others brands
like area who don't retouch and L'Oreal
who are really screaming from the
rooftops that you deserve to be
represented and you are beautiful just
the way you are being able to be a woman
in 2018 and to be vocal and speak up and
be heard last year was a real test we've
come so far by standing strong together
as women being able to choose who I
surround myself with and how I can
educate myself seek out knowledge and
seek out understanding other people's
experiences other people's cultures to
have empathy to have understanding and
consideration I love having my ideas and
my visions turn into reality take the
steps take the action and then see it
actually happen in real life your dreams
can never be too big so feel empowered
to take that next step
thanks so much for watching this video
make sure that you comment on this video
and head over to Glamour UK's YouTube
page right now to watch other videos
just like this then you lots of love
[Music]